今日は本当に欲しいのはきましたいつだろう夏ぐらいからも予約してやっと来た惨事で
ございます
これヤバイっすよていきましょう
この開封乱舞の前も今年最後だな行くぞ
うーんなんとか気付いてないことになりますマジでね欲しかった頃
で多分者をレントどうせだいけないかちょっと下ぐらいの人が見たらあーってなる感じ
です
もうこれが見てピンとくる人もいるでしょうプレミアムバンダイでべずもん adven
ツアーのせいシリーズが始まるということですもうティンときたでしょ皆さん
そう今回私が買ったのって呪文といったらこれでしょみたいな品物があるわけですよ
ライブ勝ちだ言ったピンも付いてるえっじゃないん
てしまい山へので自分見てたなぁ
あれはな見た方がいいただなんかこう仲間内で喧嘩ただけ
喧嘩ばっかりで嫌な気持ちになりましたここそれがいいかもしれないんですけどそれが
やっぱ子供じゃないですか
喧嘩するんですよ子供はいやーなんかも本当にグレイモンが大好きでもう
グレーもシリーズが一番好きなんですよだけてみましょう
マジではデジヴァイスだよ初期ので呪文の
多分2014年検定のやつだから連打それ棒
プレミアムバンダイになる会に登録しないと買えなかったらしくて
僕はもうプレビュー版剤使ったんじゃないんですけど無理やり海賊してね
買いましてどうぞがちだやばいやばいやばいやばいバイバイ
うわぁ
オーナーが懐かしすぎで何かが出てくるためですよあグッズ倍数です
村には歴戦のポケモンじゃないや葉やべ裏にゃん歴戦のデジモンが書いてあります
ちゃんとしたねオメガ思いますねまずゲージバナー
熱い税マジで地盤とベンチャー最終回が本当にもうたぶん今見てもすぐなければそれ
くらい感動するものです
もう
開けます
いやこれ開けない方がいいのかなぁだけよちなみに一番超えてますじゃあカラーリング
は2種類ありまして
太一カラーとヤマトから僕はの鐘にグレー問診ずなんで縦にグレーもなぁによってます
すごいがちだ
ああっ2もう一人ちゃってきたっ
で二倍三とずつかというと万歩計のなんかバトルとか楽しみたいん
どうですかね
それにこれをで区伴北の物語始まります
いきます
きたああああっこれでで場が選びますパターンもバレもご今日も断然開けもんですよね
ん
まあ喜んでる水でデジヴァイスでしたあちょっと気に入るかわかんないんですけども俺
宛に者っていう自慢動画でしたーじゃあ
def
em
でしまいですよ
で自分の反応を示している
これぞ家に行ってしまうがいるのか
デジョンなあー